hi i'm max saltenstahl welcome to
architecting with google cloud
have you ever wanted to know how those
ads end up inside your mobile apps
inviting you to install something else
how does machine learning work to figure
out which ones are the right ones to
show
i was pretty curious so i invited chang
vp of engineering at moloko to join us
hi chang welcome to the show hi max
thank you i'm happy to be here can you
tell me a little bit about moloko and
what your role is moloko
is a startup and then we want to build
and deliver the world's best vertical
cloud service for online advertisement
and marketing businesses
by helping them unleash their data or
the power of their data
using our ai and big data processing
technologies
so
i'm using an app on my phone i see an ad
inviting me to install something else
can you walk me through the life cycle
of how that ad gets through all of these
systems and ends up on my screen we
start working with our customers who are
typically mobile app development
companies and then their marketing teams
come to us and then commission their
advertisement campaigns because they
wanted to you know sell their apps or
have more people use their apps install
their apps engage with their apps and so
on so that's their key goal
that they achieve through moloco
and when we receive these ad campaigns
on the other hand we have lots of mobile
users out there right around the world
billions of users using you know phones
or typically similar kind of form
factors
you know tablets and so on so whenever
they use their devices
some apps are running and then these
apps keep creating the advertisement
slots
so these are called ad spaces or ad
inventories and then
we basically want to fill these ad
inventories by showing them the most
relevant
and helpful advertisement contents to
them
and to do that we need some matchmaking
and then this matchmaking is done
through what we call the advertisement
exchanges or ad exchanges these are
similar to the stock exchanges like nice
and nasdaq where supply and demand meet
together and then you know arrive at the
the right
outcomes through online bidding we
receive these ad inventories
not directly but through ad exchanges
and then
whenever we receive this bid request we
quickly evaluate the value of this
ad space relative to our
advertisement
customers campaigns and then we use a
lot of big data and machine learning
technologies to make a decision on
whether we should participate in that
bidding or we should not and then if
you're going to participate at what
price should we bid for right so we make
these quick computations and decisions
and then when we respond uh again back
to the ad exchanges the exchanges
collect this information and then run
the auction online auction and then if
we happen to win then we own that
particular ad space that is created at
that point and then we show our
customers ads through that space so the
unique thing about this industry and
using ml for this industry is that we
have to
come up with quality inference result
but very timely as well because you know
think about the stock exchange right
when you announce that there is this
supply the demand has to make a bid very
quickly in an online ad it's the time
the strangeness of the time
is actually even harsher because when
you open a publishing app that ad slot
doesn't wait for you forever it's
usually you know gonna wait for say
about a hundred millisecond or 150
millisecond within that or after that at
the proper ads need to show up otherwise
it's considered a failure so we when we
receive this bid request through the ad
exchanges we have to make that decision
very quickly typically within 100
millisecond and then that 100
millisecond includes networking latency
and our other infrastructure latencies
as well so the actual amount of time
that is left for ml inference is
actually even smaller it's typically
about 20 millisecond or even less
sometimes so but still we have to make a
very relevant uh predictions about this
particular user
and the contents so um and and also we
have to use many ml models not just one
because we have to guess
the say you know the user's interest
level about these campaigns many
campaigns
and then we have to predict how likely
the user is going to use this app or
they respond to the advertisement and
then use the new app over time and then
create even more lifetime value we also
have to predict the market conditions at
that point in time because everything
keeps changing so that we can derive the
right bid price as well so all these
models
need to work together sometimes in
tandem and then we still have to meet
the 20 millisecond latency so that's a
the the crux of technical challenge that
we're dealing with and so we use a few
you know uh
we learned a few lessons by working in
this industry long enough and then
creating values so for example we are
using
a relatively shallow
dnn models
so it's not that deep and we realize
that unlike you know natural language
processing or image processing
these inferences that we made for this
advertisement businesses doesn't need to
be that deep but we still use a lot of
features so it's shallow but very very
uh
wide models that we use
and it's okay for us to spend a lot more
time and resources for training these
big but shallow models but the inference
needs to be done very quickly that's why
we're using shallow models we're using a
lot of other
big data processing technologies to
reduce our response time as much as
possible but i guess that that probably
requires another session
wow those are some impressive numbers at
least i think they are
was it a challenge building something to
handle all that how did you scale up
yeah so the the scale is indeed a big
challenge here as well so um you know
the the number of bid requests that we
receive from the ad exchanges
that's already astounding because we're
receiving multi-million requests every
second which leads up to you know about
300 billion requests every single day
compared to what nice deals with for
example they handle about 2.4
transactions every single day we're
already two orders of magnitude larger
than that so you can imagine how big and
you know large this infrastructure is
in general and that's because this you
know
the phones are just pervasive it's just
so ingrained with our lives and then
there are so many people using this all
the time
so we're you know really handling a
huge scale for example like more than 10
billion devices
reach richard through our system every
month we're actually serving the ad
inventories coming out of about three
million unique publishing apps we're
doing our ad campaigns over 250
countries around the world
and then
the number of
ad impressions the actual advertisement
shown to the end users
that's more than 20
billion impressions every month and then
every single second we're actually
running more than 15 million uh model
inferences
uh so this this scale is the biggest
challenge along with the
the time
the strict time latency that we have to
abide by as well
so two really big challenges you've got
a latency challenge you have to make a
lot of responses very very quickly and
you have a big data challenge creating
and processing all of that data every
day for your data science and machine
learning pipelines wow
i am really excited to dive into the
architecture of all of this how did you
make the magic of ad serving happen with
all of that data
on top of google cloud receive
advertisement campaign commissions from
our advertisers through directly you
know through the you know front-end or
through api
we receive their request and then we
create internally this thing called
campaign data structures along with the
actual creatives
that the customers created to show their
end customers or the the device users
and creatives are really you know the
image files or video files or the text
that are shown as part of the
advertisement right so this builds the
the core campaign structure then these
are stored on data store
google managed data store system
because this requires sql-like access as
well
and then
on the other end we keep receiving this
bid request huge number of bit requests
through the add exchanges so we have a
dedicated system called the bid
processor
it's running on top of gke and then at
the peak we run i don't know thousands
of containers per region
to to keep sustaining uh these input
rates so when we receive this bit
processor each bid we then uh need to
choose a few campaigns or large number
of campaigns that we need to evaluate
against basically we need to make a you
know decision hey for this bid request
basically for this particular
user using this device at this point in
time with this kind of contents and
context
which of our campaigns
are good matches so we have to do that
prediction using machine learning
technologies so that's done through you
know our
custom tensorflow serving infrastructure
running on top of you know the gk
containers as well
then
uh when you when you run this model
inference of course you need to extract
a lot of data about the user
uh and then the current status of the
user which we call context information
and the user's
profile that's all public information
collected through various channels
and then our previous bid history
because the chance is that we might have
served this user for our campaigns many
many many times before so we wanted to
learn from our previous bidding
histories as well so we collect all this
data
stored in bigtable and bigquery so we
read these things out from bigtable and
bigquery very fast and then you know
handle some of these things process them
and then turn them into the right
feature sets for machine learning models
and then feed them into the tensorflow
serving okay so that's what happening at
the bid time and then when we
decide to respond to the bid request we
generate a bid response and then send it
back to the ad
exchanges now when we win this uh the
exchanges let us know that okay now you
want this ad spot why don't you actually
show the result so the the result is
shown through the cdn service and then
when the user the the mobile phone user
actually responds to this
the the response signals also come
directly sometimes to us or sometimes
through these umpires as i mentioned the
mmps so these impression signals click
signals and further engagement signals
are collected and then
come back to us
and then we collect all these signals
through our notification processors and
event processors
these are important not just because we
need to proper properly generate our uh
building record for our customers but
also to collect the data so that we can
keep training our models right all these
transactions that we do
are just great training examples for our
models so that's
you know
really really critical infrastructure
again collecting this feedback and then
we have to keep these things
in the same place so we use big table
again a lot and then bigquery a lot for
that so it seems like that bid processor
is sure doing a lot of work how big is
the kubernetes cluster that you need to
run and how do you make it scale good
question the short answer we're relying
finally now just relying on purely just
gke scaling uh feature set
um our beat processor is the biggest uh
set of containers of course we have many
others but let's just talk about the
beat processor alone it is using about
two and a half k notes at the peak time
uh for processing incoming bid request
and um and it keeps increasing our
business grows
and then initially we started off with
our in-house scalar system to manage the
cluster for a while but then recently we
evaluated gk's um native scalars a few
of them and then realized that just
relying on strictly those is actually
better now so we're using just
horizontal pod scaler and cluster auto
scaler
offered by gcp now okay let's talk about
the data a little bit you said 170
terabytes being generated every day
how do you store that process that use
it for your training and analysis
so we as i said uh we keep receiving
this bit request and then all the
follow-up signals from the ad exchanges
about our bid results and also directly
from the uh the mobile devices about the
impressions and and so on so all this
huge amount of data arrive again at our
um infrastructure through gcp's load
balancer
and then um we store them in bigtable
sometimes the raw data in gcs because
sometimes we have to replay them
and then if it's very structured and
then if it needs to
be handled by our data scientists we
also store some of them in bigquery as
well
so we're probably one of the biggest big
table users of gcp right now
and and all these raw data are stored
here uh scattered at various platforms
and then um
we we read them out for two purposes one
for training and second for analysis by
human okay so for training we actually
created a huge number of data flow jobs
so that we can read these things out and
then turn them into the um
the machine learning feature sets which
we then feed into our um coop flow
running on our vms
uh and then these are actually finally
getting into
when when we you know finish
training our models
some models are trained hourly some
models daily some some models a little
you know less frequently but whenever we
end up you know finishing our models
properly then we load them onto our
custom tensorflow serving infrastructure
which is integrated into our online
bidding infrastructure which i already
explained so that's one one data flow
part and then the other part
our engineers and data scientists
continuously need to look up this data
to see whether we're heading in the
right direction whether we can improve
something or whether the market
situation the macro situation helped
change it significantly that warrants
our model update or significant model
redesigns or insertion of new models and
so on so that pipeline is typically done
through
the the online analysis tools
we're a big user of blocker system the
looker system as well so looker running
on top of bigquery is a big data
processing pipeline for us as well and
tell me more how is dataflow helping you
move all of this data around given the
immense scale of your platform yeah
dataflow really reach data out of
bigtable bigquery and google cloud
storage
and then transform them into
feature sets
the easy integration with bigtable and
bigquery was uh both in terms of reason
right that was a big in
or motivator for us to try this out
um
we we run you know over
1 300 data flow jobs every day and then
then process as i said more than 170
terabyte every single day
and the largest data flow job that we
have currently uses up to about 7 000
virtual cpu hour per job
and um
and and so that's very cpu intensive
uh we also use data flow service based
shuffling a lot for performance gains
these days too what led you to choose
bigtable for storage it gives a very
good um
latency and throughput at the same time
the key value reason rights um you know
over 10 000 qps at less than
i don't know a few or six or seven
milliseconds when we use especially ssd
nodes that's just so fast and scalable
as well
uh we're handling about
about you know 220 megabytes per second
those so the threat throughput is also
great and then the uh the embedded
garbage collection uh system or
capability is also quite helpful because
we can just automatically forget all
data without worrying about or purging
any of those things
that is definitely a lot of data
processing and a large number of
requests so how do you optimize all of
this so that you can keep costs under
control the challenge is that our scale
keeps growing significantly and yet your
opex needs to be contained so for
example
last two years our scale has grown more
than 3x
so in terms of number of bid requests
that receive as well as the number of
bid responses that we generate
both more than 3x
so in terms of bid responses we're now
handling
or generating more than um
700 billion responses every single month
but we track for example our
unit cost so
for example the
how with one unit dollar
how many bid responses are we able to
generate that's for example one metric
that we use to measure our efficiency so
that cost efficiency has been
sort of
slightly going up
last year
but then we realized that well we had to
contain that so we actually decided to
spend a lot of engineering resources
optimization resources by taking
advantage of a lot of gcp capabilities
as well
um so it has started to come down and it
it looks a little more stable now and
then some of the key technologies gke
native scalers are helping us a lot
because we can scale in and out very
easily
and then we also now use more diverse
types of nodes even including
you know preemptable vms
so those things are all very helpful
that's great
so why did you end up choosing google
cloud for this platform that you built
pay as you go pricing helped us
bootstrap our business even when we were
very very small like we were able to
you know
start growing our business very easily
by just simply riding on top of very big
and reliable general purpose cloud
operationally we also couldn't afford to
have a big ops team
our dev team had to just focus on you
know delivering the right infrastructure
code and then ml the right ml models and
serving infra training infra so we
started off with very lean operations
team
now we are a little bigger but you know
i would say that more than 80 70 of our
operations are offloaded to the gcp team
thanks to their capabilities and
responsiveness so that's always a big
help
um
you know stack overflow is very helpful
as well because gcp engineers regularly
monitor it and um
and then you know there are a few other
specific things that we really enjoyed
on top of gcp like you know data flows
service space shuffling
and big tables latency
optimization using ssds
and then bigquery
sql performance improvement over time
then integration with looker and bi
those things have been super helpful as
well
thank you chang very much for joining us
and sharing a lot of insight into how
and why you built this ad serving
platform on top of google cloud that is
so cool i now understand a lot better
how those ads show up on my screen
what it takes to build a very latency
sensitive high performance ads platform
on google cloud and maybe a little bit
more about the immense power of some of
these tools
if you liked what you saw
please like and subscribe and check out
the playlist architecting with google
cloud for more videos like these thanks
for joining us
[Music]
you